虽然说他刚开始跟我谈恋爱的时候，
我不知道他是有老婆，
老婆怀着孕，
但是当我知道了他有老婆，
老婆怀着孕的时候，
我没有跟他分开，
现在遭遇的就是我该有的报应，
果断的买单离场。
今年30岁，
自己有两个男子，
然后有四个门店是在经营的，
在深圳我2023年的时候认识了一个男的，
谈了四个月，
我朋友就跟我说感觉他有点奇怪，
后面我就发现他其实是已婚了，
还有老婆，
还有一个孩子是怀着孕。
2023年到2025年这两年期间呢，
断断续续就没有跟他断，
在这期间他一直帮我招人，
招聘，
做人事嘛，
可以说是为了帮我招人，
中间他还丢失了工作了，
现在是一个失业的状态。
2024年的时候呢，
我又认识了另外的一个，
是在大厂工作的，
有3个月之后就去见了父母，
你说你跟他谈恋爱的时候不知道他已婚，
不知道他老婆怀着孕，
那当你知道了之后，
你还跟他谈吗？
知道了之后还是没有断，
就是有点不太理性，
当时他说他为了给你打工，
给你做人事，
她自己丢了工作，
这然你也信啊，
有没有可能他原来那份工作就不咋地呢？
是也是不太好，
因为他的那个工作不是大厂嘛，
她是做it的，
是一个游戏研发的一个公司，
后来你又认识了。
一个新的男朋友，
那这段关系呢？
这段关系就是断断续续，
没有说跟他说明白，
分手，
就这样子，
姑娘，
其实事儿不能这么干啊，
这事儿这么干可危险了，
第一，
你有钱，
你有事业，
你越是有钱有事业的女人，
在感情上越是要利益，
真真的不能这么干，
这么干太危险了，
我知道这一个是我自己其实最大的错误，
就是没有跟他说清楚说明白，
所以后面现在就发生了很多的事情，
导致我事业上有点危机了，
现在哦，
那你说发生了什么事儿，
后面就是认识了第二个男生，
去见了他的父母，
上个月就被第一个，
就是他趁我不注意的时候偷考了我手机上所有的信息，
通讯录，
聊天记录，
手机相册，
就是被他发现了，
我去相亲了嘛，
并且去见了父母，
然后现在他就是通过我的数据嘛，
到处去打电话给我的朋友诽谤我，
让朋友那些不要信任我，
有一些朋友他是建议我去报警，
然后我也去报警，
他现在就是到我的门店来搞事，
找了我的店长和他招聘的一些人，
可能大概有十几个人是他招聘找的，
这些人就是想要抹黑我，
侮辱我啊等等，
就是每天在找事情，
我不知道这个人他的目的是什么，
然后有一坨他说跟我要钱嘛，
然后当时他跟我要了四万六，
然。
然后我去找了律师跟他谈，
其实四万六我是可以给他，
但是他要给我签一个协议，
就是从今以后拿了钱不能再联系我的朋友，
不然的话我就要追究他的责任，
并且归还我，
这是四万六，
但是他当时他就是要钱不签协议，
他要这4万六的基础是说他给你做人事，
给你招人，
你没有给他发工资呢，
还是说他在追求你的时候花了钱呢？
还是因为他有什么成本呢？
他为什么要这46000呢？
基础是什么？
他也找了一些理由，
就是说在招聘的过程当中，
在线上充值的一些钱，
以及他在我的其中一个门店买了一台电脑，
还有一个就是她二三年租了房子，
我偶尔会去她那里，
她的意思就是说这个房子的钱应该由我来出，
那我现在应该要怎么样去对待这两个人？
我感觉第二个男朋友这个事儿，
如果人家已经知道了你这一段不堪的过往，
这选择权就在人家手上了，
我跟你说，
你最大的成本就是第一第二段恋情被搅黄，
第二在事业上受一定的影响，
名声上受一定的影响，
但最起码现在你这个人生命安全是没啥大问题的，
对吧？
他不至于要了你的命对不对？
他就想要钱，
那我觉得这是自己的报应，
就应该痛快的给，
虽然说他刚开始跟我谈恋爱的时候，
我不知道他是有老婆，
老婆怀着孕，
但是。
我知道了，
他有老婆，
老婆怀着孕的时候我没有跟他分开，
现在遭遇的就是我该有的报应，
果断的买单离场，
不需要签什么协议，
其实因为你签这个协议也没有用，
当时我是担心说他拿了这个气笔，
后面还会继续，
非常有可能，
但是对于你来说的话，
第一，
反正我现在谈的这个对象，
我就打算黄了，
被你搅黄了，
第二，
我的名声呢，
也被你影响了，
但是我承认，
我承认我自己当时做错了，
我愿意为我自己当时做错的这件事情买单，
一旦你的心态变成这样了，
他就再问你要不要钱了呀，
我这个男朋友我承认我就被你搅黄了，
黄了就黄了呀，
第二就是，
呃，
我的亲戚啊，
朋友啊，
打电话你打吧，
我所有人都知道我确实是做错了，
我承认我做错了，
我愿意为我做错的买单，
我要是你的话，
我这四万六我直接给他老婆，
我都不给他，
我直接给他老婆说我对不起，
我的存在对你造成了伤害，
我愿意承担我自己的这个错误，
我愿意买这个单，
我直接找他老婆，
给他老婆钱，
我王飞律师是这样，
他的原话就是说即使没有认识我，
他们的婚已经是在离的路上了，
他是这样子，
后面也是确实离，
离了，
我说你说这个有屁用啊，
事实就是他拿着这个把柄吗？
对不对？
他没离吗？
你知道他没离吗？
你还跟他睡吗？
这就是事实吗？
离了，
已经离了，
就算离了，
我这钱我也愿意给他老婆，
您说当你的心态调整到这个位置的时候，
这个男人。
再也没法拿捏你了，
如果你又怕我现在谈的这个对象变他搅黄，
又怕，
诶，
这个亲戚朋友同事知道我曾经啊犯过这样一个错误，
他拿捏你一辈子。
人就是这样，
一旦有一天我就是横下心来，
我承认我当时就是鬼迷了心窍，
我确实是伤害了另外一个女人，
我愿意付出代价，
就算全世界的人知道我当时做错了的话，
我也愿意承担我自己的过错，
一旦你把心态放到这个位置的话，
这个男人再也拿捏不了，
你明白吗？
就算对你现在的男朋友的话，
就实话实说，
我当时做错了，
他当时跟我说他是单身，
我跟他在一起了，
我跟他在一起了之后，
我对他产生了依赖，
后来我知道他没有离异，
但是我也没有很果断的跟他分开，
您说选择权交给人家对方，
那对方愿意接纳你是他的事儿，
不愿意接纳你认，
还有就是他招来的那些人，
能用就用，
不能用开掉，
你只有这样釜底抽薪，
否则的话你永远摁不住他，
你越是担心，
哎呀，
他是不是要曝光我什么的，
你又得给他钱，
你担心他是不是要跟我爸妈说这个事儿，
跟我男朋友说这个事儿，
你又得给他钱，
那一辈子狗皮膏药一样，
他粘着你。
是的，
他已经全说了，
他把所有的信息都发给我相信的那个男朋友了啊对，
现在就是两个人都对，
以后再相亲的话，
我就明说我有这段过往，
对，
我最近也反思了很多，
一直看您的视频，
就是不应该，
之前很糊涂，
什么事都很不。
清醒的去做了，
承认自己，
我给钱，
我也不给他，
我给他老婆给他离了婚那个老婆，
第二个男的就是相信的那一个的话，
是需要跟他去坦诚真诚嘛，
我现在的态度就是我啊已经分手了，
不理不悔，
他们来我就取证，
然后接着我就起诉了，
这个我感觉对第二个人就是坦诚，
来龙去脉，
所有的事情极度坦诚就是无坚不摧，
决定权在人家那个手上是吧，
咱就是说如果这个谈不起的话，
这个谈不了的话，
咱最起码还有事业，
还有两套房，
还有门面，
我不能让这个男的拿捏我一辈子啊，
我后面要谈他应该是一个什么样的人，
我现在其实很迷茫的一个状态，
我现在事业被搞得也是有点不太稳定的嘛，
事业不稳定该及时止损就及时止损，
如果你觉得他频繁的出现在这些场所，
会影响到事业的那个什么的话，
重大选择阶段就是当断则断，
杀伐决断，
就没有说被逼到绝路的，
我要是遇到这么一个人的话，
老娘就算亏钱卖房子，
亏钱卖这个门面，
我也不会让你占到我半毛钱的便宜，
如果是我的话，
我会这么干，
他现在的目的很明确，
他就是想要来动摇军心嘛，
让那些人走吧，
因为我这边招人简直是招聘的，
成本比较高嘛，
那要求也比较高，
所以搞得我现在心态也有点崩，
不管怎么样的话，
咱自己的底气要在这儿，
底气是什么？
我在哪儿，
我也能活下去啊，
我就算。
因为我深圳这房子卖了，
我这东西都卖了，
我换个地儿啊，
我照样能活下去啊，
我老跟大家讲一个事儿，
这事儿的话可能特别适合你，
每次啊，
我们女孩子啊，
一想到哎呀这是什么名声啊，
这个东西的时候，
总觉得要压死个人，
我老给你们举一个例子，
你要在电梯里放个屁，
你感觉活不下去了是吧？
哎呀，
太羞愧了，
你要在三亚海边放个屁试试，
没人听得见，
没人闻得到，
明白这个逻辑吗？
我今天我可能在这个圈子里面啊，
同事啊，
什么下属啊，
知道我曾经怎么怎么样的，
人挪活树挪死，
就不管怎么样的话，
反正有路有退路，
我现在就是这两个人，
不用去搭理他了啊，
我感觉是这样的，
就是杨幂说那句话，
极度的坦诚，
就是无坚不摧，
当有一天我承认我就是做错了，
我就是该有这个报应，
那心态一下子平衡了，
今天这个男的做的事儿就是我该遭遇的报应，
你要是说你没有勇气面对当时当下的社会关系，
那我大不了我就卖掉这些产业，
卖掉房子，
我换个地儿，
如果你要足够强大，
我就在这儿对，
我承认我做错了，
我该赔钱，
我赔钱呀，
我该道歉，
我道歉呀，
我遭了报应了呀，
那这男的还想拿这个事儿来要挟我吗？
我欢迎你说，
我都恨不得拿这事儿起号，
我薇姐，
那我应该找一个什么样的对象？
我现在今年30，
这几年都是很忙自己的工作，
你这样，
你下次遇到有眉目的，
你再花300块钱来问我，
好，
就这样啊，
拜拜，
我觉得这事儿我就是跟简单的讲一下。
尤其是自己能赚钱的姐妹，
你一定要听龙飞姐讲的这个话啊，
在感情这件事情上，
一定要立利真真的清清爽爽的，
不然的话太麻烦了，
真的太麻烦了，
她本就不该找这个男的，
这男的跟她就不是一个档次，
不是一个实例，
用那贾冰老师说那个话是什么档次，
跟我又看一样的电视啊，
该买单买单，
该承认错承认错，
记得点赞关注哦。